why should you read one piece where do I
even start maybe just keep stumbling
across this anime and finally have given
into finding out what all the hype or
annoyance whatever you think it is is
all about well let me tell you with only
a few years left to go in the series and
the beginning of the final Saga now is
the perfect time to come aboard the
straw hat ship and sail to the one piece
along with the rest of the fandom or
maybe you might already be a full
unbeliever and know just how absolutely
earth-shatteringly brilliant this piece
of fiction is and you just can't help
but want everyone you know to experience
it too like for me it's my mate that you
might know of Davis who asked me for a
video on why he should start one piece
actually I have read the beginning of
one piece but the problem is I'm a manga
collector and I have box sets one two
three and four right and I stopped right
after box set one which is basically the
end of the crocodile Arc okay the
problem is I moved to a different
country different continent and now I
don't have box sets two three and four
to pick from and I usually like to read
it physically I don't want to read it
online because it's just a long series I
don't want to like go online on the
internet and just scroll scroll scroll I
read my mom go on the toilet okay every
time I poop okay my favorite pastime was
picking up a volume of one piece going
to my toilet reading one to two chapters
and then getting hyped basically I do
love one piece I do want to continue I
think I'm just gonna wait until like
Connor finishes his one piece because he
has the physical additions at his house
I'm just gonna wait till he finishes it
and then I'm gonna borrow it or if I go
on vacation back in my hometown I'll
just I don't know maybe I can Marathon
but I probably won't anyways I do want
to continue reading one piece
[Applause]
well here is the super short really not
long at all answer chapter one a brief
history of One Piece now I don't know if
you've ever tried to convince someone to
take the plunge and start reading the
series but it can be quite of a hard
sell watching a 26 episode series can be
enough of a commitment by itself but
asking someone to read or watch 1 000
chapters slash episodes it can seem
downright daunting for very obvious
reasons not to mention that maybe some
people are turned off by the cartoonish
looking art style thinking it's not as
serious or cool as some of their other
favorite series well I'm here to change
your mind about that thanks to a uh
let's say questionable four kids dub and
a few other factors one piece has had a
hard time growing its fan base in the
west compared to a series like Dragon
Ball or Naruto but let's look at the
facts this is the most successful manga
of all time and one of the most
successful pieces of literature Ever One
Piece has outsold every other comic
series but Superman that means that its
sales numbers have beaten out both
Spider-Man and Batman whose publication
histories predate one piece by many many
decades and the estimated sales for the
series plays 80 to order its author
within the top 10 best-selling authors
of all time he's just past Dr Zeus and
soon one piece will even outsell a hairy
Potter simply put one piece with a
serialization spanning 25 years is a
worldwide sales Juggernaut why because
it's just that good before we get
started though you might want to know
some of the basics so what is one piece
about one piece takes place 20 years
after the execution of the notorious
King of the Pirates gold Roger on The
Executioner's stand Roger announced the
world that he left his treasure the one
piece hidden somewhere out in the
world's most danger accuracy the grand
line a terrifying strip of ocean that
spans Once Around the Globe the
announcement of this great treasure led
to a great age of piracy which brings us
to our protagonist Monkey D Luffy a
rambunctious young pirate who has rubber
Powers thanks to eating a devil fruit a
magical type of fruit that bestows
special abilities to someone who eats
them but at the same time also renders
them unable to swim a pretty big
drawback in a story that takes place on
the high seas and so throughout Luffy's
Adventure he gathers together a crew of
equally unique characters to fight side
by side as he takes on Rival Pirates and
the world government in an attempt to
fight the world's greatest treasure
overall there are really four great
qualities that make one piece Stand Out
Among its peers the World building the
plots the characters and the tone aren't
there any more qualities than these that
make one piece fantastic of course there
are but we don't want to get into any
dangerous spoiler territory in this
video and dampen your experience of the
series so without further Ado let's get
into chapter two the world of One Piece
if you ask the average fan what their
favorite thing about one piece is a lot
of them will say it's outstanding World
building if all you've ever seen is
promotional images it probably seems
like one piece is just a nice little
story where our crew sails around the
world getting into hijinks what I
definitely wasn't ready for when I
started the series was a complex web of
political Intrigue that easily stands on
the level of a series like Game of
Thrones or Lord of the Rings so if you
really enjoy fleshed out fantasy worlds
you will definitely fall in love with
the world of one piece this world is
filled with pirates searching for the
ultimate treasure the one piece but
along the way our crew visits a lot of
islands each with its own unique
governments culture creatures Etc and so
one Island may be filled with
prehistoric dinosaurs and battling
Giants whereas the next one is an
expansive desert Kingdom one Island may
be based on feudal Japan and another one
might be a dream Fields Candyland
straight out of a Disney movie and the
wildest thing about all of this is that
all these diverse places somehow form a
cohesive whole we don't simply stop off
somewhere and then Sail Away into the
Horizon never to think about these past
Islands ever again instead they all
interact seamlessly with one another and
the history of the world each kingdom or
Island the strawheads visit are
connected politically through the world
government a shadowy organization that
claims to uphold the peace and defend
the people from the evil Pirates but in
reality causes just as much or arguably
even more suffering as the Pirates do
the world of one piece is composed of
many different factions that move
independently from our main characters
and while the protagonist strawhead
Luffy certainly makes his mark on the
world he's just one small small fish in
a very big pond of characters while the
story sagas are shaped by the straw
Hat's actions the world is always moving
and shifting behind the scenes as well
between each major story arc ichiroda
shows us what the major players of the
world are up to elsewhere in no other
series will you see a fan base gets so
ecstatic about something as seemingly
simple as a newspaper but when big news
Morgans drops the latest issue you
better believe we're about to get some
mind-blowing updates about what's going
on without favorite characters simply
put this word doesn't seem just like a
game board for places to move on around
on it feels like a real living breathing
place and we care deeply about its many
inhabitants Oda has filled each and
every of these islands with so much care
and consideration that we're really on
the edge of our seats while we wait to
see how the complex political Dynamics
play out in the end and that is all
thanks to chapter three the character
and so of course we have to talk about
the stars of the show The Incredible web
of characters and wow does one piece
have some fantastic ones I mean with
over 1 000 characters in the series
there's a little something for everyone
here really but Central to one piece is
of course the straw hat crew our main
character Monkey D Luffy is unlike any
other Shonen protagonist just on the
surface level he seems to share some
essential traits with other Shonen
Heroes he's got the brains or black
thereof of Goku and a lofty goal like
Naruto but no one has the conviction
that Luffy does really and while he
really wouldn't do too well on his
standardized tests he has an intuitive
emotional intelligence that allows him
to make friends everywhere he goes more
than his rubber body his true power is
the way that he relates to others and
fights for those that he cares about
most of the time he's Carefree silly
even but when it's time to get serious
he'll send a a chill down your spine and
you'll be cheering for him when he gives
villains what they deserve which usually
is a really big punch the rest of the
crew is also fantastic the absolute
badass swordsman Zorro the greedy
Navigator Nami the Cowardly sniper who
saw piso way Chef Sanji the Cotton Candy
Loving reindeer Dr Chopper and a singing
skeleton named Brooke as well as some
others that I won't spoil for now
because their joining can come it's a
bit of a surprise I guess every one of
these characters not only has
spectacular Feats but they have dreams
and convictions that match their
Captain's dream to become the pirate's
King and while they're fun and even
silly on the surface they all have depth
as we learn about the tragedies they
suffered in their childhood that made
them who they are today we fall in love
with this cast of characters also you
will definitely 100 cry when you get to
some of their backstories so just be
ready for that of course our main crew
are only the beginning the straw hats
also encounter many many others on their
travels and some standouts are the
amazing villains the Marines are tasked
by the world governments to hunt down
the law-breaking Pirates which means
that our main cast constantly are on the
run from fearsome members like Captain
smoker or Admiral akind however there
are also of course opposing Pirates such
as the seven Warlords of the sea which
includes Fierce and intimidating
characters like the criminal mastermind
crocodile or the greatest swordsman in
the world's Dracula mihawk when we're
introduced to these characters they
appear as insurmountable obstacles some
of them are literally impossible to even
touch and so of course it makes it all
the more satisfying when Luffy and his
crew use their resolve and their skills
to overcome these villains and save the
innocent people on the islands they
encounter and speaking of those innocent
people the straw hats have their fair
share of allies on the sea is of the
ground line too some are royalty who
rule the various Islands they visit and
liberate such as nifatari Vivi the
princes of alabaster but some are even
fellow Pirates like the fan favorites
Trafalgar law and then of course there
are the legends who either in the past
or present have shaped the one piece
World itself people like gold Roger the
pirate who on the execution stance
started the great age of piracy by
telling people across the world to go
and search for his treasure the one
piece throughout the adventure of One
Piece you'll meet a fascinating cast of
people and if it sounds like a lot well
no worries there Oda takes his time in
each location and with each character to
let us get to know each of them as
people and to fully develop them
throughout the story it's one of the
many reasons that one piece's length
actually works in its favor it's all
killer no filler which brings me to
chapter four The Plot the plot of one
piece is another fantastic reason that
you you should read this series the
amazing thing about one piece isn't that
it has over 1 000 chapters it's that it
has 1 000 chapters and it's still going
strong the arcs being published right
now are some of the best one piece have
to offer and there's one simple reason
for this the mangaka Ichiro Ora planned
his story from the very beginning I know
that this seems trivial but you'd be
amazed at how many authors don't
actually know how their story will end
when they begin publication they just
kind of start from a premise and make it
up as they go along 25 years ago Luffy
set out to find the ultimate treasure
the one piece he's still searching for
that treasure and many are skeptical
that whatever it will be in the end will
be disappointing like the treasure will
be the friends you made along the way
however Oda Sensei has already gone on
record saying that the treasure is
something physical or at least part of
it he has had the final panel and the
overall story of the series planned for
decades and while he does insert fun
details and ideas along the way to
expand on the world that he's created
the broad Strokes of the story are
already well thought out I mean it would
have been one thing to have a great idea
for a pirate adventure and just letting
Luffy start his journey without having
the end in mind but eventually he
probably would have run out of ideas but
ever since the beginning Oda has been
constructing a story with One Singular
goal which honestly makes it such an
impressive series not just among manga
but among literature in general one way
that you can see this is with Ichiro
oda's masterful hints and foreshadowing
characters will be mentioned in the
early beginnings of the story only to
show up and play a very important role
hundreds of chapters later at points and
that really just goes to show the
thorough planning that went into
creating this masterfully structured
story not to take digs too hard at other
series but many of them seem to be
developed based on a central interesting
premise but eventually really start
falling apart the longer they get
because the storytellers didn't begin
with the ending in mind let's just call
it the JJ Abrams effect let's just leave
the world of anime for a second and
think about how TV shows like lost or
the much maligned Star Wars sequel
Trilogy Begin by Abram setting up so
many Mysteries so fans get sucked in by
all the Intrigue the problem is that
Abrams has not figured out what the
solution to the mystery really is and
seemingly also doesn't care leading to
his properties having terribly
disappointing endings many anime series
seem to suffer from the exact same
problem for instance in Bleach a series
that I really hold dear the soul Society
was a fantastic early Arc however it
does seem like titekubo the author
wasn't sure what should happen
afterwards so they just rinsed and
repeated with a new kidnapped Ally to
rescue and a new assortment of powerful
baddies to fight Dragon Ball Z kind of
does the same thing as well and two of
course can't forget the ending of Naruto
when we found out that big spoiler
Warning by the way skip ahead if you
don't want to hear this it was aliens
all along I granted one piece also has
some moon and space stuff going on but
that's always been well established for
hundreds of chapters instead of suddenly
pulling it out of nowhere at the very
last minutes most anime also deal with a
problem I call power creep the problem
of running into an impossibly strong
villain having the heroes develop a new
power up to defeat them and then rinsing
and repeating over and over until the
powers are just so absurd and don't fit
into the established scope of the
narrative anymore and while one piece
does have cool powers and power-ups it
avoids the problem of power creep that
we see in so many other Series in an
early scene where for example introduced
to one of the literally strongest
characters in the entire series dracul
mihar The Greatest swordsman in the
world one of the seven Warlords of the
sea I mentioned earlier in that
encounter Luffy's crewmate Zorro whose
goal is to become the world's greatest
swordsman himself faces off against him
Zorro who we've seen effortlessly take
out opponents left and right before this
moment is absolutely annihilated by
mihawk and so thanks to this scene and
some others like it we early on get to
see the power ceiling of the world and
that way future power-ups don't just
seem like massive [ __ ] out of
nowhere and instead they seem in line
with the properties of the world as
we've known it right from the start the
consistency of one piece is just
outstanding even the quote-unquote bad
arcs or at least the least favored ones
among the fandoms often surpass the
qualities of many other normal stories
are there occasionally flaws or
inconsistencies
is surprisingly Still Human After All
But the positives of this series
especially giving its massive length
outshine the negatives by far and this
is really mainly thanks to chapter five
the overall tone another reason to watch
One Piece is its tone and this
encapsulate relates a lot of things as
you might guess when Matt Owens a
producer of the upcoming Netflix live
action 1p series was talking about
adapting the series he said one piece
does three things it makes you laugh it
makes you cry and it makes you say holy
sh first and foremost something that
really makes one piece Stand Out Among
its peers is its sense of humor sure
other Shonen often have gags and bits of
humor sprinkled in as well but one piece
really has laughter baked into its core
I mean just look at some of the
character designs but just the
characters itself and the jokes in this
series are just hilarious and the
scenarios that they get themselves into
can be just as funny Luffy having rubber
Powers is essentially just a stretchy
cartoon man sometimes to fight he blows
himself up into a massive balloon once
when fighting a character with
food-based powers he valiantly ate his
way to Victory with the verocious
appetite that only is Shonen
protagonists could have some people do
criticize one piece for its occasional
and Goofy art style which is fair it's
subjective but the truth is that this is
one of its greatest strengths really not
just because it's usually very funny but
also because it makes the emotional and
very serious moments hit just that much
harder like the contrast between you
know just be sitting there just enjoying
your goofy pirate manga when suddenly
you're openly sobbing I don't care if
you have a Heart of Stone you will cry
when you see the suffering that this
cute reindeer has endured for instance
and when you see some of the ridiculous
Stakes that many of these arcs get to
you will be openly stunned when an
entire country of people and characters
you've grown to love are shreddably at
stake and the only possibility of saving
them means Luffy defeating a villain who
has already utterly defeated him
multiple times before that how can you
not be on the edge of your seat and even
if you know deep down that things should
probably work out fine because there are
still hundreds of chapter to go it still
won't stop you from jumping out of Joy
when Loom fee finally beats the big
Baddie lots and lots and lots of reasons
that you need to check out one piece
from the World building to the
characters to the story this is a
must-read experience of media
experiencing the story live along with a
dedicated fan Community isn't something
that you want to miss out on and once
you get caught up you can always come
back to this channel here to enjoy some
of the theories and character analysis
that I've been working on or if you
don't care about being spoiled and you
want to start right now how about
watching the best one piece theory that
you will ever see yes